les vacances de la Toussaint se
poursuivent la semaine prochaine pour
vous donner quelques idées de sortie
deux invités vont me rejoindre de la
Bergerie Nationale de Rambouillet
également du musée de la ville de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines juste le temps
de revenir sur cette grande fête du jour
Halloween la fête hériter et des pays
anglo-saxons et célébrés aujourd'hui et
après une période plutôt calme de
passage à vide même il semblerait
qu'elle fasse un nouveau recettes en
France
et oui c'est aujourd'hui Halloween
petits et grands se déguisent pour
recevoir des bonbons ou jeter un sort la
boutique party fiesta du centre
commercial de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
a été prise d'assaut beaucoup beaucoup
de décorations et beaucoup de produits
d'accessoires pour les enfants également
tout ce qui va être les petits sauts les
petits sacs à bonbons ce genre de choses
là les chapeaux également très très
demandés parmi les surprises de cet
Halloween le succès des déguisements de
squelette pour bébé et longuement du
public malgré la crise
les clients aura dépensé en moyenne 25
euros pour sa soirée d'horreur on a fait
un premier bilan et pour l'instant on a
largement atteint nos objectifs et pour
préparer Halloween en bonne et due forme
deux accessoires s'avèrent
indispensables le faux sang et les
citrouilles à la ferme de Gally depuis
samedi parent et enfants viennent
choisir et dessiner leur potiron ils
prennent une petite citrouille dehors il
amène un animateur on leur ouvre le
chapeau donc c'est après cette vider un
petit peu tous les filaments les graines
et après nous appelons une fois que la
citoyille est toute propre et après on
construit la trouille avec eux si vous
le citron méchant plutôt gentil beaucoup
de dents pas beaucoup de dents
elle est méchante pourquoi tu l'as voulu
méchante la citrouille
faire peur une fois qu'elles sont vidées
on met la petite bougie à l'intérieur et
donc la nuit on va l'allumer la nuit
d'Halloween sur la terrasse et elle
restera illuminée chaque après-midi
entre 200 et 30 citrouilles ont été
sculptés à la ferme de Gally la plupart
finira en soupe ou en beignets mais
n'oubliez pas avant de vous régaler un
seul mot d'ordre pour Halloween s'amuser
à faire peur
effectivement c'est pas très rassurant
tout ça bonjour Jérôme Delsalle
animateur la Bergerie Nationale de
Rambouillet et bonsoir également à Lucie
Sauvageot vous êtes responsable de
l'action culturelle pour le musée de la
Villa Saint-Quentin en Yvelines déjà un
premier mot vous allez fêter Halloween
donc pour l'instant non c'est pas prévu
vous avez pas vous déguiser vous allez
pas suivre les enfants on va débuter par
le musée de la ville durant ces vacances
beaucoup d'ateliers sont proposés il y
en avait d'ailleurs cet après-midi
c'était autour du béton à la découverte
du matériau le plus utilisé au monde ça
c'est plutôt bien passé la fréquentation
était bonne très très bien passée on
avait une fréquentation du début des
vacances mais bien les ateliers des
vacances justement pour le musée de la
ville c'est un moment important pour
faire venir les enfants
c'est un moment très important et qui se
passe chez nous à la fois les enfants et
les parents on tient à ce lien familial
et on fait des ateliers toujours avec
les différentes générations ça peut être
les grands-parents aussi pas forcément
ses parents
mais c'est important justement
on amène vraiment les enfants et leurs
parents à réfléchir sur la ville sur
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'une ville
qu'est-ce que c'est que ces matériaux de
construction qu'est-ce que
l'architecture et c'est vraiment un
moment d'échange avec eux c'est très
important pour nous parce que c'est des
ateliers pour le grand public ce qu'on
ne fait pas le reste de l'année donc
c'est un moment tout à fait privilégié
on va revenir sur les ateliers qui vont
suivre la semaine prochaine peut-être un
mot concernant Rambouillet aussi pour la
Bergerie Nationale là aussi les
animations que vous organisez sont
adressées à toute la famille les enfants
restent avec leurs parents tout à fait
tout à fait exactement les parents les
grands-parents avec leurs enfants sont
encadrés ensuite par des animateurs pour
les activités les jeux les activités
manuelles mais les animateurs sont là
pour les activités avant tout ce sont
les parents qui sont avec les enfants et
qui peuvent participer en même temps à
tout ce qu'on propose sur la ferme
pendant ces vacances de la Toussaint et
la thématique cette année cowboy et
indien tout à fait le détail tout à
l'heure alors les ateliers du musée de
la ville pour continuer il y en a
plusieurs à suivre vendredi par exemple
de novembre en relation avec
l'exposition actuelle justement qui est
autour de la ville c'est rêvons la ville
très bon la ville comment ça va se
passer alors c'est un atelier qui se
déroule avec une visite d'abord une
visite comptée dans l'exposition pour
leur présenter les différents projets
utopiques ou au contraire des projets
ambitieux mais qui ont été réalisés soit
sur 50 ans en Yvelines soit dans le
reste du pays même voire même du monde
pour pour qu'ils voient un petit peu des
exemples de ce qui peut se faire puis
ensuite il réalise même une maquette de
ville ils deviennent même aménageurs et
urbanistes pour voir ce qu'il y a dans
une ville comment la construire des
vocations est-ce qu'il faut réserver
s'inscrire pour réserver absolument
c'est sur réservation
de novembre 16h 16h ça dure 1h30 ça
coûte la somme modique de 3 euros en
plein de grands tarifs c'est tout à fait
simple on parle de ces différents
ateliers on peut évoquer aussi celui du
samedi 3 novembre plus belle la ville
plus belle la ville c'est un atelier
autour de la ville durable et du
développement durable où on aborde des
questions des enjeux de société comme la
biodiversité le
la question des transports comment des
transports peuvent être respectueux de
l'environnement différents questions que
les enfants découvrent à l'occasion d'un
jeu de loi puis ensuite pareil de la
même manière il construisent là cette
fois-ci une maquette à partir de modules
de bois d'une ville durable cette
thématique de la ville ça les passionne
les plus jeunes c'est une thématique qui
est difficile d'aborder au départ il
faut leur expliquer pourquoi on pourquoi
on travaille sur cette problématique là
et puis très vite ils se rendent compte
de ces enjeux et ils rentrent tout à
fait dans le dans les ateliers en
général ils en ressort très content je
voulais juste évoquer aussi un dernier
atelier il y en a plusieurs qui sont
organisaient mais celui du dimanche les
villes pour les petites bêtes alors
parce que les petites vêtes aussi ont
droit à leur maison fourmis escargot par
exemple fourmis escargot là ce sera plus
facile de les intéresser avec ça c'est
un atelier d'intervention artistique
donc on a une artiste Léa le Bricomte
qui vient au musée et qui révèle sa
manière de travailler elle a même a fait
une maquette pour escargot une ville
pour escargot qui est présentée dans
l'exposition donc on présente aux
familles et aux jeunes puis ils font une
ville ce sera une ville portable
portative pour pour eux et qui sera pour
insectes pour la ramener à la maison
comme ça ça fera aussi plaisir aux
parents pour amener les insectes que
faut réserve la Bergerie Nationale de
Rambouillet la réponse juste après ce
micro-trottoir vos idées les idées des
yvelinois des cinq continents pour
occuper vos enfants durant les vacances
la médiathèque notamment on sort on va
au bowling au cinéma et on en profite
pour faire plein de courses pour
préparer Halloween on a fait également
des jeux de société en fait faire
moi-même des activités manuelles de
je cherche des idées par internet mais
aussi on va à la médiathèque maintenant
on se promène dans le parc on a bricolé
un petit peu ensemble
avec ma fille ma grande fille
de sortie des balades en forêt
puis quelques parties de jeux on a
nettoyé la voiture voilà on a fait des
tas de petites choses en fait
je les promène avec moi je les emmène au
parc si il fait pas trop froid ou parc
de 50 ans voilà la base de loisirs
nettoyer les voitures nettoyer la maison
c'est bien d'utiliser les enfants voilà
pendant les vacances faut que ce soit
utile on s'intéresse à la Bergerie
Nationale vous faites pas laver les
voitures
c'est cowboy la thématique c'est la
deuxième édition vous l'aviez fait l'an
dernier exactement ça avait très très
bien marché donc on a reconduit cet
animation pour cette année ça avait eu
beaucoup de succès beaucoup de monde
étaient venus pour participer à toutes
les ateliers donc il y a deux grands
thèmes le thème des cowboys et le thème
des Indiens avec des activités manuelles
des jeux pour les enfants donc sur les
deux thèmes et ça se termine entre 16h
et 16h30 par l'attaque de la diligence
puisque les gens qui viennent déguiser
bénéficient de tarifs réduits et donc
tous ceux qui sont déguisés peuvent
participer à l'attaque de la diligence à
la fin de la journée donc il y a deux
clans un clan indien exactement
et les animations justement ça permet de
revenir une fois si on a été indien on
peut revenir à la fois d'après en étant
cow-boy tout à fait concrètement ils y
font quoi dans ces ateliers les cowboys
par exemple dans les cowboys il y a des
petits jeux genre lancé de faire à
cheval le jeu du lasso des petites
courses à dos de cheval mais manche à
des petits tours de poney des balades en
calèche et puis pour les Indiens c'est
plutôt des activités manuelles
fabrication d'amulettes porte-bonheur
des petites armes mais en carton bien
sûr pour l'attaque de les diligences à
la fin de la journée et pourquoi cette
thématique tout de même des cow-boys et
des Indiens c'est venu comme ça on est
sur une ferme avant tout avec beaucoup
d'animaux donc les gens viennent aussi
visiter la ferme en même temps tout est
compris et c'est vrai qu'on cherche à
chaque fois des animations en lien avec
les animaux de la ferme et c'est une
animation qui nous est venue comme ça à
force de discuter avec les enfants qui
viennent visiter l'affaire ils on sait
qu'ils aiment les cowboys les Indiens et
comme on a des animaux qui ont un lien
avec ce thème là ben on s'est lancé sur
cette animation et ça a très très bien
fonctionné et ça continue à bien
fonctionner depuis le début des vacances
l'an dernier 5000 visiteurs à peu près
au moins autant cette année et je pense
qu'on va dépasser puisque là on a fait
sur les cinq premiers jours près de 2000
visiteurs et on est ouvert pour ces
animations là jusqu'à mercredi prochain
jusqu'au 7 novembre donc tous les
après-midi de 14h à 16h30 c'est une
grosse organisation une grosse
préparation vous embauchez des gens
aussi pour pour l'occasion pour
l'événement on a une équipe d'animateurs
permanent qui sont là pour donc encadrer
les enfants et préparer toutes les
animations tous les ateliers et
certaines personnes de la bergerie plus
quelques bénévoles qui ont déjà fait des
stages viennent nous donner des petits
coups de main pour encadrer donc les
enfants au cours de toutes ces jeux
c'est une obligation pour vous
d'organiser ces animations parce que sur
un site comme celui de la bergerie on
peut se dire que le succès est assuré
forcément il y aura du monde pendant les
vacances les familles vont venir voir
les animaux mais vous voulez organiser
plus oui en fait le but du jeu c'est
qu'à chaque vacance il y a un thème
différent donc pour les vacances de la
Toussaint c'est le thème des cowboys et
des indiens mais à chaque vacance quand
on est ouvert on organise des animations
vraiment très très différentes pour que
les gens ne reviennent pas toujours pour
voir seulement les animaux de la ferme
le public et le faire revenir exactement
le faire revenir et puis surtout que les
enfants passent un bon moment avec leurs
parents c'est important au-delà de tout
ça alors je m'adresse à tous les deux
d'organiser justement des animations
pour ses enfants que les parents aient
un lien avec leurs enfants pendant les
vacances c'est important
long terme pour vendre ensuite leur
production donc on fait vraiment le lien
entre le producteur et le consommateur
le week-end suivant donc du vendredi 9
au dimanche 11 novembre donc l'animation
s'arrêtera le mercredi pour laisser la
place au grand marché fermier comme
chaque année pendant le weekend du 11
novembre merci à tous les deux d'être
venu sur ce plateau voilà donc quelques
idées pour occuper vos enfants pour vous
occuper également les grands durant ces
vacances de la Toussaint prochaine
édition du 7 8 demain dès 18h demain 1er
novembre une édition qui vous sera
présentée par Catherine zulato je vous
retrouverai lundi toujours à 18h le 7 8
qui se poursuit je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée n'oubliez pas que vous
pouvez retrouver tous nos reportages et
tout nos programmes sur notre site
internet et les réseaux sociaux pour les
commentaires laissez vos avis bonne
soirée